hi Matt here I wanted to share with you
one of my favorite podcasts Freakonomics
radio Freakonomics radio has more than
10 years in 500 episodes worth of
answers to your biggest questions with
the help of fascinating guests including
CEOs artists and Nobel laureates make
sure to check out their recent series
about the economics politics and ethics
of returning the World's art to its
makers it's fascinating join me and
listen to Freakonomics radio wherever
you get your podcasts
I've always been curious why we give
human characteristics to non-human
things for example we use gender when we
refer to our cars our tools even our
storms like hurricanes today we explore
gender on people and things
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
today I am super excited to be joined by
Ashley Mart who is an associate
professor of organizational behavior at
Stanford GS speed Ashley's research
focuses on gender equality and inclusion
and she teaches a course in managing
groups and teams welcome Ashley I'm
super happy to get a chance to speak
with you thank you so much Matt I'm I'm
really excited to be here awesome well
let's rock and roll and I literally mean
that I'd like to chat about how I first
came to know your research I read about
a rock study you did that shed
interesting light on gender and gender
roles can you please share your rock
study what was that all about so in this
study we were trying to capture how
important gender is when we think about
what it means to be human and so usually
the way people do this is they look at
faces or they use neural Imaging and
oftentimes this is because it's really
hard to isolate social categories when
we're thinking about human beings they
come with a variety of them so you know
when looking at any given person we can
see their race their age their gender
their level of attractiveness it's
really hard to isolate the importance of
Any Given social category and so what we
did was we thought we would use the
process of anthropomorphism
and for everyone listening
anthropomorphism you do it all the time
I guarantee it's essentially treating a
non-human thing as if it was human as if
it has unique emotions or personality
you know we do it all the time we see
faces in plugs on the wall like you know
we treat our pets as if they're part of
the family we talk to our plants or our
cars and what this allows us to do is
really create a human out of something
that's not there and see which social
categories go along with that and so
what we did in the lab with The Rock was
we had participants come in the lab and
we gave them a ripper Rock so a five to
seven inch river rock and a bunch of
googly eyes some pom-poms Sparkles
paints markers and embarrassment of
riches of materials and we asked them to
make a pet rock to create a human-like
Rock to make the rock come alive and so
they were given about 15 minutes to
decorate a human-like Rock and so once
they finish that task we he asked them
the importance of different social
categories in doing that task so how
important was gender while you were
creating a rock how important was race
or age or sexual orientation a number of
different social categories that are
usually important when we look at a
human being and what we found was very
interesting in my opinion almost
everyone used gender when they were
anthropomorphizing their Rock and it was
very easy to see you can see it with the
eyelashes with the rosy cheeks with the
Beards the long hair the jewelry it was
just very apparent the gender of this
rock while other social categories were
harder to tell and what was also very
interesting about that study was that we
found that gender was also the most
predictive social category in how
human-like that rock was seen to be and
so that study really showed us how
important gender is in in humanization
that to me is just fascinating not only
because of the result and I think it's
interesting that rock and roll spelled
very differently really make a
difference and I applaud your creativity
in the research design and how fun I
mean it sounds like your lab looked like
a kindergarten art center but it really
made some interesting difference
I want to stay on the conversation of
non-human things because I hear that
you've looked into the impact of
assigning gender to technology things
like Siri and Alexa but what did you
find and what can we take away from your
work on this assignment of gender to
technology especially in the world of AI
and chat GPT technology is being
increasingly anthropomorphized as
technology is fulfilling more human-like
roles more social roles if you will
we're seeing it imbued with more
human-like qualities from chat Bots to
Virtual assistants technology is being
created in human-like ways and with the
study that I just talked about we
realize this interesting phenomenon is
you know gender is really facilitating
the process of seeing something as human
and so how is that going to affect the
way in which we interact with gendered
versus non-gender technology and one
reason it's important to explore the
relationship is actually because gender
stereotypes and Technology are very
harmful so when we imbue Siri and Alexa
with a female name and a you know female
voice what we're doing is reifying these
stereotypes and roles of women that
women are more helpful and they're kind
and they're caring which are actually
quite problematic but the results of
Malia and I rock study what it really
showed is actually gender is this
humanizing force that allows people to
interact with non-human things as if
they're human and so we looked at that
very question in the study that you're
talking about where we thought that
gender might provide a way to feel more
attached or connected to our
anthropomorphized technology and so we
looked at this in a number of ways one
was through Amazon reviews and we found
that you know with robotic vacuums for
example of when people anthropomorphize
those robotic vacuums and gave them a
gender they saw them as more human-like
and they used more affiliative language
when they talked about it so they use
words like I loved this product you know
this is my friend they gave it a name
they really liked the product it and
they gave it a higher rating and so that
was an interesting finding and so we
decided to test it more experimentally
where we looked at Voice assistance
autonomous vehicles and what we found
was even just using a pronoun so
describing a car as a she versus a he
versus not describing it with a pronoun
at all we find that people feel more
attached to gender technology in part
because they see it as more human-like
and so really that study Unearthed this
Paradox of gender where you know gender
is problematic it's reifying some really
problematic stereotypes but it's also
this humanizing force that allows us to
see something as more human and so
there's really a tension between
amplifying these gender stereotypes and
also promoting anthropomorphism
I see this happen all the time where
people give gendered associations with
things that aren't real I was in a
company recently where the conference
rooms were all named for women and
that's that's interesting and we
actually on this show when I interviewed
chat GPT we put the typed responses into
a voice simulator and we had to choose
what voice do we use and we consciously
chose a female voice because we thought
it sounded less threatening than male
voice so you're making me question
decisions I make in decisions I see all
the time so thank you for that it's very
provocative
you did some work on the difference
between identity aware and identity
blind approaches to race and gender can
you define what is meant by these two
approaches and what did you find and
what recommendations come from that
research yeah I'm really glad you
brought this research because it
actually Builds on the importance of
gender so this is really outlining the
problems with gender and so to answer
your question about you know defining
identity awareness and blindness so the
formal definition is these are
ideologies around how to best approach
differences in diverse settings and to
break that down a little bit there's
really two approaches to navigating
diversity there's some Nuance there but
really they fall into two categories one
is about embracing differences
amplifying differences recognizing
differences and another is ignoring
differences or de-emphasizing
differences really focusing on what
people have in common and we've seen
this a lot in the race literature if
you've heard of color blindness and
multiculturalism these are in essence
diversity ideologies one is saying we
should be aware of race differences we
should talk about them and another is
saying actually we shouldn't you know
we're all people we're all humans we're
all Americans we should just really
ignore race in favor of a common
identity and so a lot of research this
is not my research a lot of research in
fact over a hundred papers have looked
at race diversity ideologies and a lot
of it has found that multiculturalism or
this awareness approach is a better
strategy it leads people to feel more
included it allows people to recognize
discrimination or unequal opportunities
you know you really can't recognize
differences and opportunities if you're
not talking about differences it makes
people feel less anxious it just has a
host of positive consequences and so in
my work which is recently published I
looked at the implications of for gender
so you know looking at let's take the
exact same approaches to difference that
we're talking about for race and just
apply them to gender so is it good to
discuss amplify emphasize gender
differences or minimize them
de-emphasize them in favor of
similarities and what was interesting is
I found the exact opposite results for
gender compared to race so I actually
found that when you tell people to
emphasize or amplify gender differences
it's actually increasing stereotyping it
you know is related to more bias less
support for diversity policies so you
know it's having this Divergent effect
the exact same approach to diversity as
having a Divergent effect for gender and
why this is happening is because the
types of differences that are being
evoked for race and gender are actually
quite unique when you tell people to be
aware of race differences they usually
think of things like culture or cultural
backgrounds or they think about you know
experiences have people are treated and
opportunities so inequality
discrimination and these are really
helpful differences to be mindful of and
so you know it leads to all these
adaptive outcomes for women that's not
really what's happening that's not what
people are thinking about they're not
really thinking about different you know
experiences women face different
opportunities or hurdles that women have
to overcome they're thinking about
stereotypes so you know they're thinking
yes women have all these great qualities
like what we were talking about with
Siri and Alexa you know they're
empathetic and they're incredibly
helpful and they're good mentors and
they think these are really positive
things and you know men are dominant and
assertive and sometimes we don't even
like those qualities but those are the
qualities that we associate with
leadership and so by highlighting these
gender differences we're actually
reifying these stereotypes that end up
undermining equality
and so you asked you know what can we do
with this how how do organizations end
up using this what advice would I give
and I guess it would be twofold one is
that I can't really support monolithic
diversity strategies because what I'm
finding in my own work is that the exact
same approach to diversity where people
are told to embrace you know differences
is leading to Adaptive outcomes for
racial minorities and maladaptive
outcomes for women and so this is quite
problematic you don't really want a
one-size-fits-all diversity strategy and
then the second would be to focus on the
right types of differences I think we
have broad statements around embracing
differences or being aware of
differences and what I'm finding is that
people aren't thinking about the same
differences for every group and so I
think we want to be aware of differences
like discrimination or inequality and we
don't want to amplify these stereotypes
around leadership and so perhaps
orienting people around which
differences we should be discussing and
talking about might provide a fruitful
Avenue for solving problems related to
inequality
that's really powerful what I hear you
say is in the diversity equity and
inclusion the Deni work that people do
including belonging as well that we need
to be more nuanced that we need to to
separate out these different aspects
versus treating it as one size fits-all
and I know in companies I've been in and
companies I consult in there's this go
to the diversity training and it treats
it all as one thing it sounds like it
would be much wiser and more Equitable
and a more nuanced way I hope everybody
listening reflects on that for sure
I like to turn our attention to some
other research you've done you've looked
specifically at hiring more women into
senior leadership roles what does this
do for organizations in general as well
as for Women Within those organizations
thanks for bringing up this study this
is
Sandra mats Asher Lawson and emerald
Huda and what we did in this study is we
actually looked at organizational
language through shareholder documents
and investor calls and we looked how
that language changed after hiring a
female CEO compared to not so what we
found is that stereotypes reflected in
language changes after hiring a woman
and women you know after being hired
into the CEO position tend to be
described in more agentic or leader-like
ways and so this very Act of hiring a
female CEO is actually changing a lot of
different organizational language
whether it be investor calls or
shareholder documents so what I took
away from from this research is actually
changing representation can change
stereotypes and that's reversing the
intuition that we have when we go about
solving diversity problems when we think
about Dei programs implicit bias
training really the goal here is to
change people to change their own
stereotypes to change their own behavior
so that we can create a culture that's
more inclusive and end up hiring more
women and what this paper is showing
that is that actually hiring more women
can change the very stereotypes that
we're seeking to mitigate through a lot
of these diversity strategies and it
kind of leads to this virtuous cycle so
it sounds to me as if doing both could
be really helpful hiring more women and
also continuing to work on the
stereotypes and then all of a sudden you
get this multiplier effect
absolutely and that goes back to
something that you just said which is
gei programs are incredibly difficult
and I've learned anything that
everything is more complicated and more
nuanced than I think I previously knew
and so I applaud diversity programs and
companies that are implementing them
because they're important but certainly
they are hard and they are challenging
and they require a lot more Nuance than
I think and we're currently giving
so that's that's advice to everyone it's
it's keep up with the the work but just
do the work in a more nuanced reflective
way and take advantage of your research
and that of others for sure
I want to move away from your research
and into your teaching you teach a
course on managing groups and teams can
you share two key Concepts you cover as
well as the role that communication
might play in successful team management
yes I love this course so I think groups
and teams are so important they're
really what makes organizations and you
know the human species successful we are
really a successful species because
we're able to work well in groups so
this course is a pleasure to teach we
cover a lot of Concepts so we talk about
diversity and hierarchy and process so
it's really tough to pick one of my
favorite I think one topic that covers a
lot of different problems is the idea of
process loss so process loss is really
anything that undermines A team's
performance or ability to succeed and
sometimes those problems fall into
coordination so people's ability to work
together sometimes motivation where
people become not willing to put in the
effort and sometimes ability so we don't
structure teams in ways that allow them
to use the talent within them and one of
the solutions that we talk about is
roles so it's really important in teams
to have roles to know who to turn to for
what to know who's in charge when so
that you can effectively focus on on
your task at hand and so that's one
thing that I think is really important
and I try to cover my class
and it also leads to your second
question here which is we talk a lot
about roles in communication and that's
very important so in order to
effectively communicate there are
different roles that you can have and
because you can use
and so we talk about the four player
model which is essentially breaking down
actions of Communications in teams and
so there are four possible X that one
can use in a team when they're
communicating one is a movement where
someone initiates something they have an
idea they recommend something so that's
a move and there's support where someone
amplifies something that the Mover has
said they support it they reify the
intention uh there's also opposition
where someone says I disagree I think we
should take a step back and then there's
reflection where people reflect back
what's going on as a team or some of the
Dynamics that are happening and so for
an order for effective communication to
occur we often recommend that all of
these actions are equally represented in
a team so you need enough movement to
have momentum towards a certain path you
need support to create cohesion in a
team to make people feel like they like
each other you also need opposition so
that you're not blindly moving down the
wrong path and you need reflection to
create collective intelligence so that
teams can understand how they're working
together and you know do better on the
next task so not only do those four acts
need to be equally represented in a team
dynamic or conversation but they should
also be equally represented in terms of
an individual so you want to make sure
that you're engaging in all four of
these acts if you get stuck in a role
where let's say you're the opposer
you're always saying I don't want to do
this or I don't think this is a good
idea you might just you know be seen as
the curmudgeonly person who's
disagreeable rather than the person
who's bringing up actually a very good
problem or something that people should
pay attention to and so in some I think
the class highlights the importance of
different roles and those roles could be
the leadership roles they could be your
role on a team and how you contribute
and they could also be the roles that
you play in create doing effective
communication you did my job of
summarizing very well thank you you're
supporting one of the things that I was
thinking of as you were articulating
roles and then those different movements
I think it would be beneficial for
everybody
to reflect on a recent team interaction
they have and think about what role were
you playing what roles were others
playing where were you over indexed you
had too many people doing one thing and
where were you missing and then do
exactly the same thing with the
communication that happened I often talk
about and listeners have heard me say
this that we need to reflect on the
communication that we have in our lives
in order to change it otherwise we're
doing that definition of insanity same
thing over and over again expecting
different results and you gave us some
very interesting tools and ways of
breaking that down and and thank you for
that I think that that all of us could
benefit from reflecting on are the roles
we had and the moves we and others make
well actually before we end I'd love for
you to answer the same three questions I
ask everybody who joins me are you up
for that absolutely all right here we go
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be
don't be afraid to use silence I like
this advice it's actually thinking of it
on the spot but I think silence is a
powerful tool I think oftentimes when
we're communicating we're afraid of it
and we try to fill gaps and voids in
conversation but I also think that
prevents us from listening from being
able to engage and also to exude an
executive presence the most effective
communicators I know are really the ones
who are comfortable with silence they
let the room speak they summarize what's
going on and engage with what's going on
because they're able to hold space for
for that
did I wait long enough to prove the
point so I I the the power of silence is
is very real and it signals so many
things it signals Comfort it signals
listening it invites
reflection it's a powerful tool and it's
one as you rightly mentioned I believe
people don't focus on it makes us feel
very uncomfortable
question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
I would say Deb greenfeld she's my
colleague here at the GSB and I just
love watching her communicate she uses
silence so well she is a perfect example
of someone who really is so powerful and
doesn't need to talk all the time you
know when I came into the classroom and
I started teaching mbas I you know did
this thing where I would come up to the
front of the class and I would clap and
say Hey listen up I'm here and you know
try to get their attention in that way
and I would think that I needed to talk
to be the one who's sharing information
and teaching them something and then I
watched Deb teach and she just comes up
to the front of the classroom and she's
silent and she waits for people to stop
talking and engage with her she was
really able to hold space for other
people to talk she really listens and
there's such power in using those tools
to communicate so I really admire the
way she does it I'm still learning to do
it as well as Deb I'm not even close but
I've learned a lot from her about
communication so Deb is a wonderful
person and a fantastic teacher and she
was one of our early guests so anybody
wanting to listen to the way in which
Deb communicates please please go back
and listen to that episode it was all
about power and non-verbal presence it
was was fascinating
all right question number three what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe
the words I would use are listen
gauge and express
so we've talked a little bit about
listening with silence tell me more
about engage and express
I think engaging comes from listening so
you need to do that first but really
hearing what people are saying and
engaging with those particular questions
and those particular problems I think
sometimes at least they used to have set
points that I wanted to communicate and
oftentimes I was missing what people
actually cared about or what they
actually wanted to know and there was a
better entry point for me to do that if
I really took in what they were saying
and tried to engage on that level so
that's where that piece of advice comes
from and then Express is going against
that advice in some ways it's engaging
but if there is something at the end of
that that you still want to communicate
or you still want to say that either
violates the room or you know what
people want to engage with I think
that's still important to communicate
because there should be a message that
you want to transmit and for people to
hear and listen to and leave with so in
essence you need to share your voice to
share your opinion even if it's not what
was expected did I like it I'm a big fan
of trying to remember things so it's ill
it's Express engage and listen I'm glad
you said that I was hoping for three E's
it didn't happen but you know I think it
works I think it works well actually it
was a true pleasure having you here I
learned so much I learned that some of
the things that I did and my children
did as kindergartners can actually
Enlighten us academically that Nuance is
important when it comes to diversity
equity and inclusion and really
reflecting on our roles and the type of
communication we have in teams is so
important thank you so much and I
appreciate the teachings you provided us
with oh thank you so much it was so fun
to be here
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
thank you